Speaker 1: All right.
So next part of this incredible story, part
one is Trump under criminal investigation.
Part two, a number of statements from the
attorney general, Merrick Garland, over the
last week or ten days indicating a willingness,
at least theoretically, to prosecute a former
president.
Okay.
We have been waiting for these signals.
The first signal is the following.
Here is an interview with Lester Holt that
Merrick Garland did yesterday.
Speaker 3: You said it in no uncertain terms
the other day that no one is above the law.
That said, the indictment of a former president
of the perhaps candidate for president would
arguably tear the country apart.
Is that your concern as you make your decision
down the road here?
Speaker 1: I really hope that's not as concerned.
Speaker 3: Or do you have to think about things
like that?
Look, we pursue justice without fear or favor.
We intend to hold everyone, anyone who was
criminally responsible for the events surrounding
January six or any attempt to interfere with
the lawful transfer of power from one administration
to another, accountable.
That's what we do.
We don't pay any attention to other issues
with respect to that.
So if Donald Trump were to become a candidate
for president again, that would not change
your schedule or how you move forward or don't
move forward.
I'll say again that we will hold accountable
anyone who was criminally responsible for
attempting to interfere with the transfer
or legitimate lawful transfer of power from
one administration to the next.
Speaker 1: So that is quite clear from Merrick
Garland.
That is quite clear.
And there has been an increased, increasingly
noticeable shift in this direction.
Now, on July 20th, this was about a week ago,
Merrick Garland also made very clear, and
that's the statement that was referenced.
No person is above the law, also believed
to be a signal about what may be coming.
Speaker 3: We are entering as only.
Later if there are charges brought against
a former president related to January six.
DOJ could be accused of playing politics.
How is the department?
How are you waiting for that?
Also, do you think that there is a constitutional
question here about whether you charge former
president for actions allegedly taken during
his term?
Separately, Jalen Walker.
Kaitlin Walker McConnell, answer.
Okay.
Let me answer.
Okay, look.
No person is above the law in this country.
Nothing stops us.
No, I don't know how to say that again.
No person is above the law in this country.
I can't say it any more clearly than that.
There is nothing in the principles of prosecution
and any other factors which prevent us from
investigating anyone, anyone who's criminally
responsible for or for an attempt to undo
a democratic election.
Speaker 1: So that was the first signal that
there was something going on.
And then, of course, over the last 24 hours,
we have learned Trump under criminal investigation
by the federal government, the Justice Department,
a major, major deal which we will continue
to follow.
Now, again, I don't want I don't want to be
negative.
I don't want to be pessimistic.
But do I really see charges announced against
Donald Trump by Merrick Garland?
I don't know that I do.
But I will, of course, concede.
I think it is more likely today than at any
point over the last two or three years during
which I've been asked about it again and again
and again.
Let me know where you are.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
What do you expect at this point and do the
last 24 hours change your opinion?
The David Pakman Show may not be like other
programs that you listen to or that you watch.
We actually depend on the support of our audience
to do what we do, and the primary source of
that support is the membership program, which
you can sign up for at join Pacman dot com.
We do an extra show every day called the Bonus
Show for our members.
We also provide a commercial free audio feed
and a commercial free video feed for our members
of The Daily Show, usually available 5 to
6 hours earlier than when the show goes out
to everybody.
Sign up at join Packman dot com.
You can use the coupon code.
Obama.
Speaker 3: Obama now.
Speaker 1: Obama.
And a to get a discount.
Also many other coupon codes floating around
there in the ether.
But join pacman dot com is the one and only
place to sign up.